[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
bienvenue dans sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat de
chronique et de reportag sur Public
Sénat vous le savez la promesse est dans
le titre de l'émission donner du sens à
l'actualité vous proposez des clés de
compréhension des mutations de notre
société et voici le sommaire de ce 23
novembre l'extrême droite remporte les
élections législatives au pays avec un
discours anti-islam anti-Europe
anti-écologique ger wildilders a su
convaincre près d'un quart des
Néerlandais de voter pour son parti mais
pourra-t-il former une coalition quelles
conséquences en Europe s'il met en œuvre
sa promesse de sortie de l'Union
promesse réaliser évidemment pendant sa
campagne électorale quel lien mais aussi
quelle différence avec le rassemblement
national de Marine Le Pen on répond à
toutes ces questions avec nos expert
dans une minute et puis pour notre
second débat c'est un massacre de masse
que l'on va dénoncer et analyser celui
des millions d'enfants victimes de
violence sexuelle en France depuis des
décennies moi je suis survivant je leuri
j'ai pu leur dire ce matin j'ai pu
rappeler aux membres du gouvernement qui
étaient présents leur responsabilité en
disant quement en fait l'État a une
responsabilité dans ces massacres de
masse 160000 enfants victimes chaqueé de
violence sexuelle donc c'est bien de
dire qu'on a bien travaillé maintenant
faut passer en fait de la parole aux
acte la commission sur l'inceste et les
violences sexuelles faites aux enfants
vient de remettre son en rapport au
gouvernement les mesures annoncées par
ellisabeth born peuvent-elles mettre fin
au dénis collectif comment protéger nos
enfants nos petits enfants quand les
prédateurs sont le plus souvent à
l'intérieur même des familles ne ratez
pas notre débat sur ce thème dans 45
minutes mais d'abord ce coup de tonner
donc qui se fait entendre partout en
Europe la victoire du parti pour la
liberté il ouvre une période
d'incertitude pour les Pays-Bas et
l'Union Cécile Sixou
hier soir ces militants du parti
centred- drroit n'en croi pas leurs
yeux leur opposant g wildilder le leader
d'extrême droite et son parti xénophobe
le PVV ont remporté les élections
législatives la formation politique a
raflé 37 sièges sur 150 devant les
écologistes avec 25
sièges 37
[Applaudissements]
sièges la plus grande fête au
Pays-Bas Gert wildilder habitué des
campagnes législatives a changé de
discours moins islamophobe et plus
social la stratégie a
payé ce matin autour d'une coupe de
champagne il appelle les autres partis à
former une
coalition nous sommes prêts à négocier
parce que nous voulons former une
coalition pour nos électeurs qui sont
environ 2 millions à avoir voté pour
notre parti hierous nous sommes tout à
fait disposés et aptes et nous avons
prouvé que nous étions capables de le
faire en 2010 où nous avons montré et
prouvé que nous étions capables de faire
des compromis afin d'assumer nos
responsabilités surnommé le Trump
néerlandais gviler espère devenir
Premier ministre mais pour gouverner il
a besoin de 76 sièges sur 150 pour le
moment les autres grands partis refusent
de
s'associer au-delà des Pays-Bas en
Europe victoire a été salué par
plusieurs leaders d'extrême droite le
Hongrois Victor Orban l'italienne
Georgia Meloni ou encore Marine Le Pen
en France je me félicite de cette
victoire parce que Gelders et son
mouvement sont des alliés du
rassemblement national il démontre que
de plus en plus de pays au sein de
l'Union européenne d'abord conteste son
fonctionnement et il y a vraiment de
quoi anti-européen le PVV a promis
notamment un référendum sur le maintien
ou non des Pays-Bas dans l'Union EUR
l'extrême droite caracole au Pays-Bas
quellees conséquen pour l'Europe on en
débat tout de suite avec Pascal Joannin
bonsoir bonsoiromas bienvenue vous êtes
directrice générale de la Fondation
Schuman Bruno cotrez bonsoir et
bienvenue politologue chercheur au CNRS
et au cvipof Richard verli bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue correspondant francee
pour le média Suisse bli et vous publiez
chaque jeudi le podcast café élevétic
j'accueille Émilie zapalski bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes spécialiste en
communication politique élitorialiste
pour sens public Pascal Joan question
assez générale tiens pour commencer
est-ce que c'est cette victoire du Parti
de la liberté c'est une surprise alors
oui dans l'ampleur oui parce que tous
les sondages d'opinion qui avaient lieu
encore à la veille du scrutin montrait
qu'il était dans un mouchoir de poche
mais derrière les trois autres qui sont
arrivés finalement derrière lui donc par
l'ampleur en effet c'est c'est étonnant
euh après c'est quelqu'un qui laboure le
terrain politiqueais depuis 20 depuis
plus de 20 ans qu'il est député il a
commencé sa carrière au Parti
libéral le VVD hein il a changé depuis
et en effet il a fait une campagne sur
un thème qui a été porté par tous les
autres alors donc il a pas eu besoin de
faire campagne et je pense que ça serait
très intéressant dans les autres pays
parce que le thème de l'immigration
c'est sur sur quoi a chuté Marc rutux
alors Marc rutux c'est le premier
ministre sortant qui était là depuis
2010 et donc ces premières élections
sont sans lui ouais parce qu'il c'est
une nouvelle a qui s'ouvrait c'est une
nouv il Ava R 1 r 2 R 3 R 4 donc R 4 est
tombé sur la sur la question migratoire
avec quatre parties dont deux étaient
pour deux étaient contre donc et on a
sur ce sujet je moi je pense qu'il faut
pas aller parce que toujours on
renontrera l'extrême droite et que
l'extrême droite sur ce sujet est bien
meilleur que tous les autres partis qui
viendrait chasser donc les autres ont
perdu parce qu'il venaent chasser sur le
territoire intéressant Bruno cotrez
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire de du leader
de ce parti gu wildilders donc leader
d'extrême droite est-ce qu'il a c'est ce
que nous
disait Cécile sexou dans le sujet
d'ouverture est-ce qu'il a un peu
édulcoré je mets des guillemets son
discours anti-islam alors il a peut-être
édulcoré mais c'est vrai que la
différence de tonalité est un peu
marginale c'est vrai qu'il a un peu
édulcoré mais g Wilders d'abord a été
connu effectivement pour ses prises de
position sur l'islam il faut rappeler
qu'il a été condamné plusieurs fois en
justice pour avoir en particulier
comparer le corant à mcamp il avait fait
une sorte de documentaire là-dessus qui
était assez impressionnant où il prenait
des phrases du Coran des phrases de Man
camp il disait aux gens bah regardez ce
sont les mêmes phrases en fait et donc
il a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup porter
ça puis aussi l'idée que les personnes
qui venaient vivre au Pays-Bas et venant
en particulier de pays où l'islam est la
religion dominante il venaient surtout
motivé par les prestations sociales son
parti faisaient campagne avec des
affiches on voyait des femmes voilées
qui faisaient la queue devant un guichet
de l'administration donc voilà très
connu pour ses prises de positions très
très très contre l'islam effectivement
il a continué il continue sur ce sur ce
sur ce thème mais est-ce qu'il s'est pas
rapproché dans sa dans cette campagne
électorale finalement plutôt d'un
discours à la Marine Le Pen sur
l'inflation le pouvoir d'achat et cetera
est-ce que c'est pas aussi son cheval de
batailleou oui bien sûr et notamment
d'ailleurs ça va être une des dimensions
en tout cas qu'il souhaiterait mettre en
œuvere peut-être pas de tout de suite
foncer bille en tête sur la question d'e
exit une sortie des P plus t voilà de
l'Union européenne mais beaucoup plus
sans aucun doute la question de
l'immigration desmigration en général
mais aussi la question inflation pouvoir
d'achat qui dans toute l'Europe occupe
beaucoup donc effectivement on voit
effectivement une volonté de ce point de
vue-là de venir sur ces sur ces
thématiques et de toujours toujours du
côté de ce type de parti de laisser
suggérer que les raisons pour lesquelles
les nationaux auraient tellement de
difficultés serait parce que d'autres
viennent pour émerger au budget des
prestations sociales Richard verli
quelle leçon vous tirez de ce scrutin
néerlandais d'abord les Pays-Bas de 2023
ne sont pas les Pays-Bas de 2021 en 2021
c'était la dernière élection comme cela
vient d'être dit le Parti libéral du
Premier ministre sortant ruté avait
réussi à faire une coalition mais en 2
ans il y a eu une très forte montée de
la criminalité il y a eu des enlèvements
y compris la fille de la Reine qui a été
menacée d'enlèvement par la mafia
marocaine du trafic de drogue il y a
énormément de problèmes sociétaux qui
sont apparus il y a eu une tuerie à
retard il y a pas si longtemps donc il
faut bien comprendre que au fond
wildilders en réalité il a pas du tout
changé il tient aujourd'hui un peu près
le même discours qu'il tenait il y a 2
ans mais chez c'est les électeurs qui
ont changé parce qu'il y a vraiment eu
un traumatisme ces deux dernières années
dont on ne mesure pas le poids au
Pays-Bas c'est un pays qui un peu comme
la Suède n'était pas prêt à affronter
une telle montée de la criminalité ça
leur saute à la figure et s'ajoute à ça
les grillefs récurrents sur
l'immigration qui sont pas du tout
nouveaux de la part de gerilders et un
élément intéressant c'est que celle qui
a succédé à la tête du Parti libéral
succédé au Premier ministre sortant
c'est une fille qui est née en Turquie
elle est kurde d'origine turque et ce
qui était intéressant c'est qu'elle même
a choisi de camper une ligne très dure
contre l'immigration et donc à partir du
moment où vous aviez quelqu'un d'origine
turque très dur contre l'immigration
alors franchement
j' n' plus aucune peine à voter
pourou il me semble qu'il y a deux
phénomènes qui se passent avec ces
élections et glalement c'est qu'il y a
une espèce de libération de ces paroles
assez xénophobes ass islamophobes un peu
partout on sent que ces discours là bah
il se propage encore plus dans la
société maintenant on peut dire
ouvertement des choses terribles comme
on a entendu et comme même s'il y a des
procès c'est pas grave il y a une espèce
de montée et en face c'est vrai que
c'est l'extrême droite qui est considéré
comme la plus habilité en fait à
défendre ces causeslà vous l'avez dit
mais je pense qu'il y a pas de partie
autre qu'extrême droite qui se saisit de
ces questionsl d'une façon un peu séri
avec d'autres arguments parce qu'on peut
aussi dire qu'il y a eu un dénis face au
danger d'un de d'une monté d'un islam
politique dans les pays deoup sur
l'immigration même en étant de gauche
sauf qu'il n'y a aucun parti il me
semble qu'en Europe c'est à peu près
généralisé qui se saisit qui appartient
à la gauche et qui se saisit un peu
sérieusement y compris d'une manière
musclée on pourrait très bien imaginer
ça pas en allant jusqu'aux thèses
d'extrême droite mais avec une
vision voilà un petit peu plus des
quotas de se dire bah oui on va
accueillir mais pas tout le mond neit et
on peut ajouter juste un élément c'est
que le leader du parti de l'alliance
entre les travaillistes et les Verts
donc le bloc de gauche Fran Timmermans
qui avait à priori toutes les qualités
pour représenter une alternative il
avait un énorme boulet c'est qu'il est
vice-président sortant de la Commission
européenne et donc il était complètement
prisonniur cl
ver qui est intéressant parce que c'est
une dimension dans un pays en effet où
aux dernières élections alors qui était
élection provincial mars dernier donc il
y a il y a 6 mois c'est un nouveau parti
BBB hein pour faire voilàou mouvement
agricole et
citoyen était arrivé en tête justement
parce qu'il trouvait que tout ce qui
était pour le changement climatique
c'était peut-être bien mais trop rapide
que ça avait pas été assez réfléchi pour
que tout le monde puisse accepter tout
ça donc on a bien en effet donc là
timerm c'est bah oui en effet il a
quitté la commission dont il était le le
viceroi le vice-président et parce que
il pensait gagner en faisant cette union
à droit à gauche et là il a perdu alors
ce que ce scrutin il nous intéresse
aussi évidemment avec un effet miroir
sur ce qui se passe en France sauf qu'il
y a une grande différence quand même
c'est que au Pays-Bas c'est un système
proportionnel avec une culture de la
coalition donc là on a un
guerte vilders qui arrive en tête mais
pourra-t-il former une coalition
évidemment lui il se dit
prêt je ne vais pas négocier ici mais
bien sûr nous sommes prêts à négocier
parce que nous voulons former une
coalition pour nos électeurs qui sont
environ 2 millions à avoir voté pour
notre parti hier et nous sommes tout à
fait disposés et aptes et nous avons
prouvé que nous étions capables de le
faire en 2010 nous avons montré prouvé
que nous étions capabl de faire des
compromis afin d'assumer nos
responsabilités donc oui en effet nous
sommes prêts à le faire nous sommes
impatients de le faire parce que cette
grande victoire aux élections
néerlandaises nous donne beaucoup de
responsabilité et nous voulons vraiment
être à la
hauteur côter l'Union des droites à la
mode néerlandaise peut-elle porter ger
wildilders au pouvoir oui en tout cas
c'est sûr que s'il veut détenir le poste
de Premier ministre il sera obligé
effectivement de faire une alliance avec
la droite classique on va dire donc
c'est vrai que c'est une thématique
qu'on voit se retrouver de pays en pays
à travers l'Europe alors effectivement
on le voit dans ses propos on voit que
la culture de la coalition la culture
proportionnaliste elle est tout de suite
là oui on est prêt à faire ce qu'il faut
à faire des avancés à faire des
compromis effectivement c'est une
différence principale avec avec la
France mais est-ce qu'il y a une notion
de digue comme alors peut-être que la
digue c'est beaucoup effrité en France
he c'est un autre débat qu'on a déjà eu
ici mais est-ce qu'il y a une dig au
Pays-Bas pour le moment tout le monde
dit qu'on ne fera pas alliance avec lui
une sorte de théorie du cordon sanitaire
autour de son mouvement politique et
autour de sa et autour de sa personne
mais on voit tout de suite les
problématiques que ça peut poser le
parti qui arrive en tête d'une élection
même dans un système proportionnaliste
même dans un système habitué à la
question de la coalition mais avec en
toile de fond un électorat qui est
chauffé à blanc par une campagne
électorale avec beaucoup de tension avec
beaucoup de choses fortes qui ont été
dites c'est compliqué quand même oui
c'estd si une autre coalition par temp
seéait ce serait une espèce de bras
d'honneur aux élect mais même dans un
système proportionnaliste il y a quand
même une règle simple que tout le monde
comprend qui est que le parti qui arrive
en tête il est quand même très difficile
de lui expliquer qu'il n'a pas vocation
avoir un rôle extrêmement important
ouais Pascal Joan est-ce qu'il y a une
sorte de plafond de verre quand même
même dans dans ces pays de scrutin à la
proportionnelle pour l'extrême droite
dans cette capacité justement à former
ou non une coalition d'abord il y a pas
parce que les partis d'extrême droite ne
sont pas tous les mêmes ils sont pas
tous dans la même famille monsieur
wildilders il est en effet comme vous
l'avez montré dans votre témoignage
l'ami de Marine Le Pen parce que en
effet ces députés au Parlement européen
siègent dans le même groupe que les
députés du rassemblement national mais
c'est pas vrai par exemple des
Démocrates suédois ou des vra finlandais
qui eux siègent avec les conservateurs
et donc c'est un pays en effet où il y a
17 il y en avait 17 en effet group
politique enfin parti politique
représenté dans
l'assemblée la chambre la chambre basse
du parlement néerlandais sortant parce
qu'il y a pas de seuil donc vous avez en
effet une multitude de petits partis
donc il y a 150 sièges il en a que 37 il
lui en faut 76 il lui en faut 76 donc il
en manque 40 hein allez et ça va pas
être simple pour lui parce que parce
qu'il y a non seulement le le le
personnage mais il y a le programme le
programme bon sur l'immigration on peut
peut-être essayer de trouver en effet
tous une r commune mais il y a d'autres
sujets ù il ça va être à poil à gratter
est-ce qu'il est dans la coalition mais
pas le premier ministre que ça aussi ça
peut être voilà je rappelle que les
démocrates chetoi qui sont arrivés 2è
premier parti à droite mais deuxè
derrière le Parti social-démocrate ne
sont pas dans le gouvernement on n' pas
dit Oh là mon Dieu les Suédois ont fait
un crime de l'ISE Majesté en ne mettant
pas les Démocrates suédois dans le
gouvernement alors ils participent au
gouvernement parce qu'en effet pour
voter ils ont besoin des voix et donc
vous y croyez plutôt à la coalition vous
coalition des droites Marc ruteux a mis
4 mois 4 mois pour le gouvernement 4 et
il ne traitait qu'avec quatre partis de
droite qui étaient tous à peu près s
sensible donc là je pense que on est
parti pour un moment avant que Mar donne
les clés à quiconque donc Marc va être
encore là quelques semaines voire
peut-être quelques mois parce que s'il a
mis lui 4 mois moi je pens je pense
qu'aujourd'hui la la la la la scène
politique néerlandaise est suffisamment
fracturée pour qu'avant qu'on imagine de
se rencontrer il va falloir que les
partis eux-mêmes fassent des
négociations entre eux qui va sur quel
point on s'accorde et cetera avec ce
monsieur qui est quand même un peu
particulier donc et qui veut qui veut
renverser la table donc avant dir et
donc en effet il y a peut-être une une
autre coalition mais ça sera en effet
difficile mais je rappelle quand même
que alors ça c'est
ou a de de deux élections il y a un
parti qui est arrivé en tête les de 3 4
se sont mis d'accord pour faire la
coalition alors là il revient cette
fois-ci mais donc c'est pas
impossible différ la différence de
culture politique j'adore on est parti
pourir veut faire une coalition compris
par 4 5 6 mois peut-être de négociation
en France on dirait ça AES alors vous
avez évoqué effectivement le le vote le
vote on va dire j'ai simplifié un peu
mais le vote rural dans C les élections
législatives au Pays-Bas avec ce
mouvement agriculteur citoyen alors là
il est il est quand même retombé de de
du pieddestal paril était leader il
était arrivé premier aux élections
provinciales là il arrivent en 6e
position moins de 5 % des voix et 5
sièges Richard verli est-ce qu'il
pourrait quand même participer à une
coalition avec G wildilders est-ce
qu'ils se rejoignent sur un certain
nombre de de d'idée notamment
l'opposition vous l'avez dit à une
Europe on va trop verte ou trop rapide
dans le dans le virage ver nouveau parti
pourrait participer à vraid aux deux
types de coalition il pourrait être
éventuellement aspiré par une coalition
dirigée par le parti gu wildilders le
Parti de la liberté mais si se met en
place contre wildilders une forme de
coalition nationale une union nationale
il pourrait éventuellement y aller aussi
donc c'est c'est exactement ce que
disait Pascal à l'instant je pense qu'il
va y avoir des peut-être pas des mois
mais en tout cas des semaines
certainement de discussion moi ce qui me
frappe c'est que la personnalité de de
gu builders il a beau faire référence à
2010 mais 2010 c'est une expérience qui
n'avait pas marché
euh il y a beaucoup de partis qui le
considèrent juste comme pas fiable c'est
quelqu'un qui aime la provocation en
permanence et qui une fois qu'il serait
éventuellement Premier ministre sera
dans une position encore plus je dirais
possiblement provocatrice donc ça peut
être l'épouvantail de la coalition mon
avis il y a beaucoup de gens qui ne sont
pas prêts à travailler avec lui ni comme
chef du gouvernement ni comme leader
d'une formation étant au sein du
gouvernement et donc une ion nationale
ça pourrait être le moment et ça
pourrait marcher au Pays-Bas à condition
et ça ce sera le grand problème de
renoncer à un certain nombre de choses
et là c'est les vert qui vont sûrement
perdre beaucoup de plumes ils viennent
d'en perdre sur le plan électoral mais
pour les raisons que vous venez de dire
je pense que tout l'agenda écologique va
être remis en cause et ça je trouve ça
aussi passionnant c'est pour ça que ce
scrutin nous intéresse parce que il y a
là une leçon sans doute à analyser pour
tous les pays d'Europe sur la la
rapidité Bruno cotr de cette
transformation environnementale son
acceptabilité par par par nos sociétés
tout simplement c'est aussi ce qui
s'exprime là dans les qui pour qui
pourrait s'exprimer praines é ce thème
est en train de s'affirmer il va sans
doute prendre de l'importance pendant la
campagne pour les élections européennes
et on voit effectivement plusieurs des
partis politiques de la famille
politique à laquelle le mouvement de G
Wilders appartient qui commence à
dire si je reprenais une expression qui
avait été utilisé par un
président ça commence à suffir comm à
faire ou
et l'idée aussi qui est que il y a une
sorte de qu'on aurait atteint d'après
eux une sorte de de point de non retour
d'en avoir trop demandé ou je rappelle
accessoirement qu'on a déjà dépassé les
de degrés et que on n pas sur la
trajectoire la pression la pression que
ces mouvements politiques vont exercer
au Parlement européen si les élections
européennes leur sont plutôt favorables
et pour le moment on a beaucoup de
signes qui vont dans ce sensl la
pression qui vont qui vont mettre sur
les partis de la grande coalition du par
Parlement européen les parties de
centre- droit de centre gauche va être
extrêmement extrêmement importante et on
commence à voir du côté du de la famille
politique du centre droit le le fameux
PPE on commence à voir que ça bouge
aussi que ça évolue sur cette question
donc le contraste et les clivages les
tensions sur un climat qui fait de plus
en plus
apparaître sa transformation les étés
suffoquants et des partis politiques qui
eu prennent le point de vue de gens qui
disent mais nous on nous en demande trop
sans aucun doute quelque chose de très
important dans les mois qui arrivent on
va ouvrir dans un instant un chapitre
sur les les points communs et les
différences entre g wildilders et Marine
Le Pen mais d'abord une dernière
question sur cet aspect transformation
environnementale Pascal j vous l'avez
abordé rapidement tout à l'heure il y a
quand même on parle de société
européenne fracturée là on est quand
même dans l'expression d'une fracture
entre les les les urbains et les ruraux
c'est un peu simplificateur ce que je
dis mais c'est quand même ce qui
s'exprime aussi dans les
dansit et c'est quelque chose qu'on voit
à
ça fait quasiment 2 ans maintenant moi
que je suis dès qu'on a fini la la
pandémie on va dire voilà dès qu'on a
fini le confinement les gens se sont
aperçus d'abord ils a beaucoup qui ont
quitté la ville hein euh et donc il y a
des choses qu'on peut faire mais le
rythme n'est pas n'est pas celui qui en
fait quand vous avez une publicité
aujourd'hui de voiture dans toutes les
voitures vous avez préfériz pour les
pour les les trajets courts préférz le
transport en commun mais les transports
en commun c'est bien à Paris c'est bien
dans les grandes villes mais en province
vous avez pas de transport en commun
vous avez cinq personnes dans une maison
il y a cinq voitures parce qu'il y a pas
de transport en commun si vous avez des
enfants grands vous ils ont chacun une
voiture et puis vous le voilà donc donc
tout tout est comme ça donc il faut
faire attention à ce que en effet le but
l'Europe a voulu être un des premiers à
être le sur le le la zéro émission de G
et cetera il y a un rythme ce rythme là
il faut peut-être en effet le l'amender
pour que en effet on contiennne ces
objectifs mais que en effet ça soit pas
vu comme une contrainte ou quelque chose
qui punit pour des gens qui vont se dire
bah si c'est ça l'Europe alors je VO un
bulletin pour un parti qui n'est pas
européen je sais pas s'il faut l'amender
ou s'il faut réorienter les les crédits
pour ceux qu'en ont le plus besoin mais
ça c'est un c'est vast dé le sens dé
2030 2035 compris l'urenceentendre sur
la notion de zone rural au Pays-Bas
c'estàd que ayons bien conscience que
les agriculteurs dont vous avez parlé
ceux qui sont M
forme de CO écique ce sont des
agroindustriels de l'agriculture pour la
plart c'est pas le paysan français isolé
dans un petit hameau la géographie du
Pays-Bas n'est pas du tout celle de la
France pas du tout celle de la Suisse
par exemple donc on parle surtout de
gros producteurs agricoles qui défendent
au fond un modèle assez industriel allez
comme promis on parle de de Marine Le
Pen on compare gu vilders avec Marine Le
Pen on l'a vu tout à l'heure dans le
sujet d'ouvertureie elle l'a félicité
est-ce qu'ils sont sur la même ligne
politique alors oui ils sont sur la même
ligne sur de nombreux point extrême
droite oblige exemple ils veulent tous
tous les deux limiter drastiquement
l'immigration expulser les migrants
illégaux revenir à un contrôle des
frontières nationales autre idée
partager et faire primer le droit
national sur le droit européen limiter
encore plus le port du voile islamique
mais ce qui les rapproche aussi et
surtout c'est cette façon d'adoucir leur
position au moment des élections il
s'agit bien sûr de gommer les
caractéristiques de l'extrême droite
pourquoi parce une sorte de prise de
conscience des dangers d'un programme
trop radical c'est ça bah oui d'un côté
comme de ils on compris quees positions
trop radicales ça pouvait les faire
perdre en tout cas s'il les mettait en
apparence comme ça trop fortement pour
Marine Le Pen c'était flagrant pour la
présidentielle 2022 elle revient sur la
sortie de l'euro qu'elle proposait en
2017 autre chose sur le voile pareil en
2017 elle voulait l'interdire dans tout
l'espace public et ben non elle y
renonce en 2022 et globalement en 2022
elle a beaucoup moins mis l'accent sur
les fondamentaux du rassemblement
national immigration préférence
nationale bon il faut dire que sur le
coup elle a été aidée par éc Zemour qui
a tout pris ces thématiques là grand
remplacement et qui a insisté sur ces
thèmes donc elle n'avait pas besoin de
satisfaire ça elle elle avait choisi un
thème central très proche de notre
candidat des Pays-Bas c'est le pouvoir
d'achat oui peut-être quand cela Gilders
l'a un peu imité il a eu la même
démarche oui et alors on est passé de la
rakaille marocaine he parce que c'était
aussi les termes qu'il utilisait au
moment de lancer sa campagne à des
propos bah bien plus modérés je le cite
il y a des problèmes plus importants que
la lutte contre le flot de demandeurs
d'asile et d'immigrants a-t-il dit
durant un débat pendant la campagne donc
on voit quand même la modification il
choisit aussi donc d'axer sa campagne
sur la lutte contre pour le pouvoir
d'achat et sur les questions sociales on
l'a vu dans le sujet a priori ça marche
son nouveau surnom c'est Gert milders
Gert le dou donc stratégie plutôt
gagnante plutôt gagnante mais bon il
faut transformer l'essai on en a parlé
hein tout à l'heure la coalition il faut
se trouver des alliés pour former une
coalition au Parlement c'est pas simple
et ça serait a priori le même cass-etête
pour Marine Le Pen malgré sa stratégie
d'institution ialisation au Parlement
les belles cravates les bonnes tenues
tout va bien pour ces 88 députés ça
serait la même galère finalement cette
stratégie elle est peut-être payante
pour gagner une élection avec des
personnages comme ça fort en voie et en
expression comme le montreville ders
mais elle ne rend pas la tâche facile
pour ces figures d'extrême droite quand
il passe au pouvoir c'est difficile de
trouver des partenaires c'est difficile
aussi il faut le dire de mettre en
pratique des programme très musclé si on
se retourne sur l'Italie avec Georgia
melony avec des propositions très fortes
très et ben finalement on se rend compte
que à la fois sur l'international et sur
l'économique elle a dû reculer aussi
bien sur le plan social que sur
l'immigration donc c'est pas si avec
notamment un principe de réalité sur
leusage des subsides européens on va
dire ça comme ça Bruno cotz tiens je
commence avec vous sur cette comparaison
est-ce que les comment je peux tourner
ça est-ce que les les différences entre
wildilders et Marine Le Pen sont plus
importante que leur que leur proximité
oui il y a quand même des différences
qui sont t lié déjà au au jeu politique
dans lequel les deux sont ils ne jouent
pas au même jeu effectivement Marine Le
Pen joue le jeu de la présidentielle et
fait l'hypothèse que quand on gagne la
présidentielle sous la 5e République
quelque chose se passe et un simple Swit
un simple déplacement de
quelques centaines de milliers
d'électeurs permet d'avoir une majorité
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est pas du
tout le même jeu puisque lui est dans un
jeu où il doit déjà convaincre des
alliés de le rejoindre pour faire une
coalition dont il serait le porteur le
premier le Premier ministre déjà il ne
joue pas le même jeu et ça a quand même
une très grande importance sur les
thématiques aussi sur ce l'offre qu'il
propose on voit que Marine Le Pen depuis
maintenant au moins la présidentielle de
2022 mais clairement depuis cette
présidentielle là effectivement est sur
une stratégie d'élargir ces thèmes
considérablement sur la question du
pouvoir d'achat ça vient d'être appelé
mais aussi de laisser entendre que et
bien au fond elle pourrait former un
gouvernement réunissant des patriotes
réunissant des gens qui partagent les
mêmes idées qu' pas nécessairement
membre de son parti donc voilà déjà une
très importante différence entre entre
les deux et par ailleurs Marine Le Pen a
accentué considérablement au cours des
dernières années un thème qui leur a été
commun à tous les deux il y a une
quinzaine d'années une vingtaine
d'années qui était cette idée que l'État
providence l'état protecteur c'est très
important à condition qu'on le réserve
au nationaux voilà qui est un thème
extrêmement important dans le discours
de Marine Le Pen dans le programme du
rassemblement nationale qui dire bah au
fond moi je veux pas qu'il a moins
d'État Providence je veux pas qu'il y a
moins de protection je veux simplement
qu'elle soit réservée au nationaux h euh
il a partagé ce thème avec elle il a une
quinzaine ou une vingtaine ou une
vingtaine d'années ce thème s'est
estompé par la suite parce que la
question de l'Islam a pris une
importance complètement primordiale dans
son discours politique donc voilà une
autre différence ou Pascal Jin est-ce
que ça annonce forcément un rat de Maré
nationaliste populiste aux élections
européennes euh pas
forcément parce que d'abord vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure de Georgia Meloni
il ne sont pas tous dans la même famille
politique donc pas dans le même groupe
politique aujourd'hui si on prend il y a
le groupe des conservateurs o siège les
Démocrates suédois les Vrais Finlandais
les Polonais et georia melon et puis
vous avez le groupe ID où il y a g
wildilders le rassemblement national la
Lega italienne et native sur Deutschland
qui est en Allemagne donc vous avez et
ces groupes ont à peu près une
soixantaine
d'élus aujourd'hui hein voilà donc je
rappelle que les deux principaux partis
sont à plus de 100 c'est 120 et 140 donc
penseer qu'il vont doubler et qui vont
donc dépasser les partis qui sont
aujourd'hui le PPE centre-doit et le SD
centre-gauche lors de la simple élection
2024 j'y crois pas beaucoup parce que
comme ils sont très nationalistes de
toutes les façons ils ont des solutions
très nationales alors ils peuvent
s'entendre un petit peu sur des choses
communes mais pas trop sur le chose
national donc c'est c'est pas et quand
on voit le bilan il faudrait que les
journalistes le fassent le bilan des
sortants députés idé bon bah il faudrait
voir ce qu'ils ont fait comme vote et et
pas V dit il pèse pas beaucoup
finalement sur les lois qui sont V au
pas au Parlement européen et donc il va
y avoir peut-être une progression c'est
le souhait de de Georgia melony qui est
arrivé aux affaires en Italie et qui
aimerait bien que le courant d'une
droite radicale qu'elle ne veut plus
extrême soit plus amplifié et là pour le
coup on peut dire qu'elle a des des
batteries de de de potentialité de
développement puisque il peut y avoir
Vox Espagne il peut y avoir les
Démocrates suédois il peut y avoir les
Vrais Finlandais il peut y avoir des
gens qui au côté de Marine Le Pen pour
l'instant il y a pas grand monde et
Marine Le Pen elle-même dans une
déclaration publique qu'elle avait faite
a dit que Georgia Moni n'était pas sa
copine donc ça veut dire qu'il rest il
va rester encore deux groupes euh qui
vont rester au Parlement européen donc
il va y avoir peut-être une progression
mais ça va pas être le ras de Maré ça en
effet ça ça veut dire attention si vous
ne faites rien dans le changement des
discours vous risquez d'avoir en effet
la même surprise dans un sens
désagréable mais je mais je rappelle que
ce qui va se passer en France selon les
sondages risque de se passer qu'en
France pour l'instant peut-être au
Pays-Bas demain mais pour l'instant il y
a pas d'autres parti qui va arriver en
tête dans en Allemagne je je sais cons
conséquence européen avec are vetas dans
un court instant vouliez intervenir un
mot un mot chacun rapide s'il vous plaît
par nous reste beaucoup de il y a un
principe de réalité on l'a dit par
exemple sur la préférence nationale bah
on voit que par exemple en France ça se
ferait retoqué par la Constitution pas
accepter d'immigrer on a une question de
pénurie de maindœuvre il y a un moment
et on le voit d'ailleurs même en Hongrie
on est obligé d'ouvrir les vannes parce
que sinon on a des métiers des emplois
qui trouvent pas d'employ de de de
personnalitéou on ver quelle sort les
députés
LR font à la loi ouis mais il y a un
point il me semble qui est quand même
intéressant dans ce positionnement et
qui peut avoir une résonance un écho
même au niveau européen c'est le
nationalisme économique ce
protectionnisme économique à la Trump
perdur voilà qui perdure avec Joe Biden
globalement et qui dans ce monde
postcovid Ukraine est très d'actualité
et peut vraiment avoir un écho très très
fort y compris je pense en Europe c'est
une question nationale mais on voit très
bien l'intérêt de d'être sur ce position
faudra affirmer c'est un une sorte de
nationalisme économ é voilà qu'on arrive
à se défendre en meut chasser en meut
pas Richard vouliz intervenir moi je
suis moins optimiste que Pascal parce
que ces leaders qui maintenant tous
murissent qui tous commencent à à se
rapprocher je dirais du centre de
gravité de la vie politique ils vont en
tirer les conséquences ils ne vont alors
peut-être vont-ils rester divisés
peut-être vont-ils conserver de groupes
au Parlement européen mais très
franchement ils peuvent aussi faire le
contraire c'est ils peuvent aussi avoir
une vraie stratégie commune pour
affronter ses élection européennes et
finalement retourner l'argument européen
contre l'Union en ayant justement une
approche européenne parce qu'on les
définit toujours et je pense qu'on se
trompe on les définit toujours comme des
partis nationalistes bien évidemment
qu'ils le sont mais ils sont unis
aujourd'hui par une chose c'est le
ressentiment envers l'Union européenne
et ça leur permet d'avoir un discours
européen évidemment négatif mais je ne
suis pas du tout sûr qu'ils vont en
rester à l'état de parti divisé qui se
méprisent les uns les autres allez une
réaction sur ce sur ce thème he sur
évidemment toujours la victoire de de
gardevil au Pays-Bas et les conséquences
pour l'Union européenne c'est celle du
député européen raphaë
gluxman j'aimerais qu'on prenne
conscience là de la gravité du moment
qu'on est en train de traverser l'Union
européenne fait face à des crises
immenses on a la guerre qui a fait son
retour sur notre territoire on n jamais
eu autant besoin de l'Union européenne
et élection après élection on voit
l'extrême droite remporter des succès
immenses on voit
un personnage monsieur wildilder qui a
fait campagne non seulement contre les
musulmans contre l'immigration mais
aussi contre le pacte vert européen la
transition écologique et pour un
référendum de sortie des Pays-Bas de
l'Union européenne j'accueille Audrey va
sur ce plateau bonsoir Audrey pour
effectivement évaluer les conséquences
de de cette victoire de G wildilders
pour l'Union européenne et bien il faut
savoir que l'une des mesures phares de
son programme et ça depuis plusieurs
années c'est le nexit contraction de
neederland Pays-Bas et dexit sorti vous
comprenez sorti des Pays-Bas de l'Union
européenne les Pays-Bas qui sont
pourtant l'un des membres fondateurs de
l'Union alors dans son programme
gardvilders propose d'organiser un
référendum contraignant sur le sujet
parce que selon lui il veut que les
Pays-Bas retrouvent leurs frontières
leur monnaie leur indépendance je vais
vous proposer d'écouter un extrait voilà
l'idée qu'il se faisait de l'Union
européenne c'était en 2016 mais ça a pas
vraiment
changé il serait plus facile de changer
la Corée du Nord que de changer l'Union
européenne si vous donnez à une
institution du pouvoir et à ces
dirigeants des responsabilités si vous
transférez vos droits souverains ils ne
changeront jamais l'Union européenne la
Corée du Nord bon alors un peu de nuance
quand même malgré ce vote massif pour
wildilders au Pays-Bas ce qu'on entend
ce n'est pas forcément une sortie de
l'Union européenne mais plutôt d'arrêter
de financer des programmes qui ne
bénéficient pas directement aux Pays-Bas
on pense notamment à un programme de
l'Union européenne c'est l'aide au
développement qui permet de garantir la
stabilité de certains pays hors de
l'Union Européenne et puis là on parle
aussi d'une nouvelle victoire pour un
parti nationaliste europhobe oui vous en
avez parlé des partis qui affichent soit
de très bons scores soit des victoires
partout dans l'Union européenne ou en
tout cas ils s'opposent à Bruxelles et
eux ils ne veulent pas forcément tous
sortir de l'Union européenne on pense
par exemple à la présence de Marine Le
Pen au second tour en France les partis
europhob font aussi de très bons SCOR en
Pologne en Espagne en Finlande en Italie
et bien sûr récemment en Slovaquie avec
la victoire l'élection de Robert fitzo
comme premier ministre Robert fito qui
est proorusse une dynamique qui pourrait
se ressentir peut-être dans les urnes
dans quelques mois vous l'avez évoqué
puisque le 9 juin en tout cas en France
ce sont les élections européennes en
tout cas les forces populistes elles
elles essayent de capitaliser sur cette
victoire on l'a vu dans le message qu'a
adressé Victor Orban à à vilters mais
aussi le message adressé par Marine Le
Pen écoutez il démontre que de plus en
plus de pays au sein de l'Union
européenne d'abord conteste son
fonctionnement et il y a vraiment de
quoi
et souhaite que l'on puisse
à nouveau maîtriser une immigration qui
est considérée par beaucoup de peuples
européens comme en même temps massive et
aujourd'hui totalement anarchique est-ce
CEI une mauvaise nouvelle pour le
Conseil européen oui vous savez c'est le
c'est le le Conseil qui donne qui donne
le cap c'est la réunion des chefs d'État
et de gouvernement et quand on regarde
les résultats il y a peu de chance que
le futur premier ministre ait autant
d'expérience et de charisme que Marc
ruteux or l'Union européenne on le sait
pas forcément mais elle a souvent besoin
des Pays-Bas pour créer du compromis
parce qui a une culture du compromis et
notamment pour mettre de l'huile dans
les rouages du moteur franco-allemand
qui parfois grippe un peu et dans les
relations entre Emmanuel Macron et Olaf
SCHS merci beaucoup audre vetas pour ces
informations Pascal Joan on a vu que le
brexit avait mis beaucoup de temps avant
de de d'entrer en vigueur donc on va pas
voilà tirer des plans sur la comète mais
mais quand
même quelles seraient les conséquences
d'un exit d'une sortie de des Pays-Bas
de l'Union est-ce qu'on peut se projeter
là-dedans je sais pas si on je sais pas
si on peut se
projeter on a vu le l'exemple du
Royaume-Uni qui était pas un membre
fondateur he qui est rentré qu'en 73 et
on voit que 7 ans après les Britanniques
se pose vraiment la question de savoir
s'ils ont bien fait de dire non à
l'Europe et que peut-être il voudrait
bien imaginer peut-être une un retour un
jour on voit les les Écossais dire mais
nous on est on veut revenir et cetera
donc je suis pas sûr que ça soit quelque
chose de gagnant on a l'impression qu'on
retrouve TAKE BACK control disaient les
Anglais en vrai dire ils ont rien take
back contrôle du tout ils sont dans de
grandes difficultés économiques dans des
grandes difficultés la question
migratoire ils sont sortis de l'Union ça
n'a pas réglé le problème de la
migration au Royaume-Uni donc Madame Le
Pen dit on sort de l'Europe tout est
fini maisain non il y a il y a rien qui
est fini et puis alors sur ce point-là
alors sur ce point-là moi je crois qu'il
a aucune aucune coalition possible au au
Pays-Bas parce qu'il y a aucune autre
formation
politique ça que sur d'autres points sur
les questions migratoires et cetera il y
a-être certainement des choses qu'on
pourrait trouver avec d'autres partis
pour en effet restre bre de choses sur
cette question de la sortie de du pays
je crois que c'est le seul à le proposer
je crois que aucun autre n'a envie et
que compte tenu de l'expérience
britannique même Victor Orban ou même
d'autres n'ont jamais été jusqu'à sortir
de l'Union européenne en a plus d'autres
plus ve dire dans un
P déc dans un pays habitué aux
coalitions il aurait pu av enfin même si
ça correspond à ce qu'il dit depuis des
années hein g mais c'est c'est sa marche
de N de négociation voyz en quelque
S
ve en effet crédibilité pour pouvoir
avoir des alliés potentiel il y il y a
quand même un élément important et je
pense qu'il faut en parler Richard ver
c'est la capacité de l'Union européenne
à répondre à ces critiques parce que
elles sont pas totalement infondées les
critique qu'on fait sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union aujourd'hui
tout ça se résume à mon avis à un mot
efficacité est-ce qu'aujourd'hui
posons-nous la question y compris des
instituts très respectables comme la
Fondation Schuman est-ce que l'Union
européenne est efficace aux yeux des
électeurs et je crois que tant que ce
problème de l'efficacité n'aura pas été
vraiment pris en main et que l'Union
européenne n'aura pas trouvé des
marqueurs concret de son efficacité ça
va être extrêmement difficile pour cette
campagne électorale là quant aux gens
comme ger wildilders et Marine Le Pen
ils sont d'une perversité incroyable
parce qu'ils ont compris que maintenant
si vous êtes opposant à l'Union
européenne le mieux c'est de la miner de
l'intérieur c'est pas la peine de faire
un référendum si vous faites un
référendum d'abord vous n'êtes pas sûr
de pouvoir le faire vous venez de le
dire et deuxièmement vous allez
fracturer le pays et peut-être le perdre
alors que si vous arrivez au
gouvernement et que de l'intérieur vous
essayez de détricoter de au fond de de
semer une forme de chaos et bien vous
arrivez à ce que vous voulez un un
détail important qui n'en est pas un
c'est que on a parlé de Georgia Meloni
qui est en position elle difficile parce
que son pays reçoit beaucoup d'argent à
l'Union européenne c'est pas le cas des
Pays-Bas qui sont contributeurs net donc
la position son parti des frugos
absolument donc la position est quand
même radicalement différente monsieur
wildilders il peut dire en gros lui il
dit pas j'arrête de reevoirû il dit
j'arrête de payer c'est pas tout à fait
la même chose ça rejoint un peu le le le
chapitre qu'on avait consacré cotess au
aux similitudes on va dire entre Marine
Le Pen et et Gilder cette idée
effectivement vous l'avez évoqué dans
dans votre éedito Émilie de de
prééminence du droit national sur le
droit européen ça ça les ça les réunit
quand même oui oui très clairement très
clairement même si le rassemblement
national ne propose plus un frxit oui il
ne propose plus la sortie de la France
de la zone euro non plus mais
effectivement il y a quelque chose qui
les réunit c'est l'idée que il y a eu un
abandon de la souveraineté nationale et
que depuis cet abandon de la
souveraineté nationale tout est allé à
Volot tout est et que au fond la
thématique d' d'une d'une France qui ne
maîtrise plus son destin qui décline
vient de cette de cette question il faut
se rappeler aussi que dans notre vie
politique en France la question de
l'Europe continue de fracturer les
familles politiques euh l'opinion
publique française n'est pas euh euh
fondamentalement très profondément en
faveur de progrès très important de
l'intégration européenne dès que vous
prenez des enquêtes d'opinion qui
portent sur cette question vous voyez
que la France est un des pays où
l'opinion publique est la plus frileuse
sur la question de progrès vis-à-vis de
l'intégration européenne alors que nous
sommes à la veille pratiquement à
l'avant-veille presque à la veille on
commence à parler d'un élargissement
horizon 2030 6 pays au moins donc il y a
là quelque chose chose effectivement qui
qui a une sorte de de de problème dans
lequel on se tape en permanence les
dirigeants disent qu'ils veulent une
Europe qui écoute davantage les citoyens
mais en même temps beaucoup adhèrent à
l'idée qu'on ne peut pas faire
progresser l'Europe si on écoutait les
citoyens parce que si on écoutait les
citoyens il voudrait la protection
nationale et on tourne en rond autour de
cette question depuis 20 ou 30 ans avec
aujourd'hui des des pays dans lesquels
effectivement la question de l'Europe
est en train de redevenir un enjeu très
cvant frilosité on on se croirait dans
une chambre de conservation des Tul
irlandaise il fait un peu froid sur
notre plateau bref c'est pas le plus
important vouliz intervenir moi il me
semble qu'il y a des leviers qui sont
visibles là parce que il y a eu la crise
covid il y a eu l'Ukraine mais surtout
pendant la crise covid l'Europe elle a
montré de l'efficacité mais elle a
montré autre chose elle a montré de la
flexibilité justement dans sa façon
d'imposer les choses aux uns et aux
autres exemple le déficit pour une fois
crise ou là là on on accepte d'être un
petit peu plus en déficit pour investir
pour aider les uns les autres et se reg
ça pas du tout hein oui mais non mais
c'est des leviers autre exemple les
aides d'État on a pu aider davantage les
entreprises on a pu faire sauter des
verrouses normalement qui sont très très
forts au niveau européen sur les règles
nationales et il me semble que ça en
effet ça peut être des arguments de ces
parties d'extrême droite de dire ça mais
l'Europe a la possibilité de dire il y a
des cas où on a été flexible ou quoi
mais ça on l'entend pas beaucoup et ça
ne se produit que en cas de crise et je
trouve que dommage dommage que l'Europe
soit si bonne en cas de crise mais
quand il voilà elle met du temps quand
même mais elle s'est quand même réveillé
sur les vaccins elle s'est réveillé sur
pas mal de choses mais quand tout va
bien ou quoi bah voilà c'est c'est le
gros mamouth qui qui bouge pas et qui
nous empêche en effet de faire beaucoup
de choses ou peut-être pas suffisamment
efficace pour faire connaître son
efficacité est-ce qu'on peut dire ça
aussi parce en quelques mots il nous
reste une d'accord la Fondation Rober
Chan lutte depuis longtemps sur en effet
c'est pas l'Europe qui protège c'est
l'Europe qui est efficace parce que
l'Europe qui est efficace c'est l'Europe
qui qui fait face au défis c'est
l'Europe qui avance qui Inn qui qui
voilà c'est pas l'Europe qui protège
derrière un espèce de de de avec du
passé et cetera
simplement comme vous l'avez dit on
avance en Europe quand il y a des crises
alors il y a il y a eu la crise covid on
a avancé il y a eu la guerre en Ukraine
on a pris des mesures et le problème et
la question qu' va falloir régler mon
avis pour lutter contre l'extrême droite
c'est que ce thème de l'immigration si
l'Europe n'arrive pas à s'en saisir et à
trouver une solution parce que elle s'en
est saisie mais le le le projet de la
commission de 2020 est toujours sur la
table on voit bien que c'est difficile
si on n'y arrive pas d'ici les élections
européennes on voit bien que là c'est un
sujet alors elle a réussi sur le covid
elle a réussi sur la CR il faudrait
qu'elle réussiss sur l'immigration et
rapidement pour en effet montrer que ce
sujet n n'est plus un sujet national
mais un sujet européen avec quelque
chose qui si et d'ailleurs ge il a
demandé une solution européenne et pas
une solution nationale merci beaucoup
merci à tous d'avoir participé à ce
débat Richard verl je signale votre
nouveau podcast café elvtic c'est c'est
tous les tous les mardis les ben on
suivra ça vous avez déjà le thème de
mardi prochain oui ce sera sur la colère
des maires enfin la la colère contre les
maires mais aussi la colère des mairres
contre l'État et bien voilà il y avait
effectivement le Congrès des mares on y
était ce mardi avec sens public merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat